“The immigration crisis in europe…”
“…Three children drowned…”
“…Syrian refugees…”
“…it’s become a symbol of desperation…”
“…a surge of refugees…”
“…Among the dead, several children, including
a baby girl.”
Sen. Dick Durbin (D-IL): “One issue that
needs to be addressed is the overly broad
prohibition in our immigration law that excludes
any refugee who has provided any kind of support
to an army rebel group. Even a group that
we in the United States support.”
Rep. Michael McCaul (R-TX): “This would
be a federally sanctioned welcome party, if
you will, to potential terrorists in the United
States.”
Sam Stein, Huffington Post: Could we take
more? I mean Germany is taking 800,000…
John Kerry: Well i’m not talking about taking
more on a permanent basis.
Josh Earnest: It warrants mentioning has provided
more than 4 billion dollars in humanitarian assistance.
But no thinking of bringing more Syrian refugees
to the US?
Earnest: At this point, I don’t have any
announcement along those lines.